[Music]
katie's with us in dallas texas hi katie
how are you
[Music]
katie
are you there katie
hi katie yes i'm good how are you great
how can we help
so i'm 27 000 in credit card debt
i've used up 100 of my credit
does myself a whole and i don't know
how to get out how old are you
i am 32. how much do you make a year
i gross 83.
is this the only debt you've got
it is
this is awesome i'm so glad you're here
this is a good problem to have with this
income katie we can clean this up fast
is it on one card or multiple
it's on six different cards okay that's
one biggest one being discover 12 000.
all right and you clearly want to get
out of this how did you get into it
what'd you spend the the credit card
money on
um just transitioning over from one job
to another
paying my way full credit got into that
yep crap you did not spend 27 000
transitioning from one job to another
uh
i started out that way and then it kept
growing yeah so it was kind of an
addiction yeah the problem
kept spinning
five thousand dollars transitioning from
one job to another and you're
disorganized and you overspent buying
crap you can't afford for the rest of it
exactly okay okay
so i want to make sure that we at least
change the behavior because we can help
you get out of debt i just don't want
you back in this mess you know two years
from now and so what i want you to do is
cut up the cards we're done with those
you're going to list out the debts from
smallest to largest so the smallest
credit card debt to the largest one
we're not looking at the interest rate
we're not going to do math right now
we're going to work on progress and
getting rid of this debt and so how much
how much could you throw extra at the
credit card debt if you're making
minimum payments on the rest
um
so that's the issue i have after i'm
done paying all of my bills
each paycheck i had ten dollars left the
day i got paid you make eighty three
thousand dollars where is it going
all bills
no no you told us that was your only dad
you stop you told us this was your only
dad
bill's like for house you know my rent
how much is your rent
uh 800 a month that's not it and then
electric and stuff is 450
uh my son goes to a private school
550
a month
are you married um
i'm not a single mom okay
all right so here um
the the first thing is this
the
grasping the idea that personal finances
80
behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
and so behaviors are what got you into
this
new and healthy behaviors are what will
get you out of this is that logical to
you
yes okay absolutely and so what you're
going to do we're going to put you into
financial peace university and help you
that is a nine week class
nine lessons
and we're going to teach you every
detail about handling money
and i'm going to give it to you for free
it's usually about a hundred dollars to
go through it okay
i'm gonna give it to you free because
i've been where you are scared and
didn't know what to do
and you're scared and you're by yourself
trying to raise a kid and you don't know
what to do and that right
yes okay
so what i want you to do is i want you
to use that fear
not as a paralyzing
agent to paralyze you but i wanted to
use you as the driving agent that says i
will never
be here again
i will pay any price i will sacrifice
anything i will do whatever it takes so
that me and my kid are never
on the doorstep of financial terror like
this again
no matter what it takes i'm getting out
no matter what it takes no matter what
dave says i got to do my friends think
it's weird and it's uncomfortable to me
i'm doing it anyway because i'm never
gonna be here again
right you got that this is your halftime
speech okay
it's half time and you're behind
we gotta get you to win the game
you can do this i gotta get there but
you can't keep doing what you've been
doing so george is right are you going
to cut up the credit cards all of them
no exceptions as soon as you get off the
phones say yes and mean it
yes okay i am good along with that we're
going to send you every dollar and the
premium version it'll connect to your
bank this is going to be your budgeting
app this is going to be your roadmap
this is going to tell you where you can
and can't spend it's it's your
permission to play and so once you set
that up along with watching financial
peace videos it's going to give you a
sense of control you've probably never
had because you're paying attention to
every single dollar that's coming in
from that amazing 83 000 income and
we're gonna put it to good use and every
expense that is not necessary for
survival is going to go away for a short
period of time no lifestyle no eating
out
no vacations we're cleaning this mess up
because we're sick of living on the edge
of terror or the rest of our life
right
you can eat out later stop eating out
yup we stopped eating out yeah well
something's wrong with your budget which
something's wrong with your budget
because you're not something's missing
in what you're telling us which makes me
think you're not really doing a good
detailed budget
i think this stuff is still happening to
you but i want to teach you to happen to
it
so every dollar has an assignment before
the month begins you make 83 000 a year
is our stop your retirement temporarily
do you have retirement coming out
i do stop it temporarily today
i want that money to go towards this
debt i want you to get where you ten
dollars is not okay left over
it's not that's the definition of terror
when you're by yourself
and you have to look in the eyes of your
baby and you're scared
and you know you're just you're walking
around this 300 pound weight around your
neck i want to get it off of you and so
and i don't know what else is coming out
of your check but if you can stop it
stop it anything you can stop that not
not your health insurance keep it but oh
my goodness and any scorched earth
food shelter clothing transportation
utilities and other than that kiddo
you're getting out of debt because if
you didn't have a stinking payment in
the world and you had a budget where you
were making your money behave instead of
wondering where it went your life would
be completely different than it is right
now and we haven't even moved you
towards building wealth yet
right you're going there though
okay
you promise me you'll do this stuff if i
give it to you free i promise all right
here's what i want you to do i want you
to call back and tell us how you're
doing i want you to call back if you get
any questions if you're scared you feel
like you're by yourself you're not we're
here for you
thank you
you can do this but i gotta tell you now
if you don't do it i'm gonna kick your
butt okay
okay deal
we go to dallas enough dave might find
you out there
we'll be there for smart conference you
know what i want to send katie a ticket
to smart conference as well can you do
that awesome yeah yeah we're gonna be
there october 22nd maybe we can get to
meet her i would love that
we'll arrange that yeah and that will
give her some encouragement all day long
in every area that event will ever live
out of fire under me i mean that event
is just i take notes from every speaker
on that i i love that thing it's some of
the best speakers and teachers in the
world and i i sit in the audience and
take notes every time we have one of
those yeah yeah yeah the thing is folks
you can do this stuff it's hard though
but you got to be different than the
world be not conformed to this world
you got to be weird that's why we always
yell at these people these young couple
paid off their house a while ago you're
dead free you're weird you guys are
weirdos people think i'm calling them
names i'm not calling names that's a
huge compliment when it comes from us
because normal sucks
normal is broke and scared
making a lot of money and having no idea
where it went normal as you work your
whole life and you retire and social
insecurity is supposed to take care of
you the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money is your
source come on
come on it's ridiculous and this toxic
money culture is a terrible measuring
stick to look at your broke friends and
go well i think i'm doing okay because
i'm doing something as good as my
friends toxic culture period you can't
look at the normal person's marriage and
go i want to be like that
no
because most of them don't have good
marriage they're not doing the right
stuff most of them don't have good
mental health most of them don't have
good careers you know you don't want to
be normal god did not put you on this
earth
there's a reason we look up to people
that are winning in an area of their
life is because they're winning
you know it's because they're doing good
stuff they're making a decision to
sacrifice no discipline seems pleasant
at the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness you can do this stuff
folks and katie can do it